or emotional acting this has been the
most intense thing I've ever done that
day you kind of like talked before the
scene that we need a few minutes to
really get into character because it was
definitely an emotional scene and it's
hard to just when they say action get
into character in that scene where we
find Wyatt he jolts up and starts
screaming at us and blaming us we're
comforting him in world bawling her eyes
out and actually that was the first time
I've ever like cried like like on
command like I can cry when I'm like a
mad in real life but first time I've
ever cried like acting and it was pretty
amazing I couldn't stop right I did the
scene three days in a row so that means
I cried my eyes out three days in a row
at first like I didn't want to do it
again but then I was like you know what
it's it's gonna look good and I think
it's gonna pay off it was a pretty
emotional moment you know the curious
thing is that it coincided with one of
the last days of shoot the feelings you
see on the screen are very much
what-what the kids felt that day because
it was one of the last things that they
will all be together you can feel the
sadness and the need to be together for
the last time and thank each other and
they they just let it go and they were
all crying and they were crying for real
I talked to Ben the acting coach and
Andy the director I was like okay well
what if it's a role reversal where Eddie
is talking to Wyatt calling him down and
I'm at the foot of him crying and I sort
of just turned into everyone started
crying Finn and Jack could not hold back
their tears I thought they were just
trying to like stay in the moment
whenever he liked and he was giving
directions but they were just crying and
not until after we just hugged it out
when I finished that scene I was like
still crying me and Jack was still
crying and then the producer stuff came
out to us and just gave us a big hug and
he was like man you made me cry and I
have no heart and so I was like okay
that that means a lot
feeling I'm all like they're with me and
it was just like I gave me a feeling
because we're all best friends off off
camera were best friends lifelong
friends and just being there and
moment where everyone's crying also
Wyatt why does a great actor work with
he's he takes you there I've been in
that place before I've shut myself off
from the world and just cried but I
think that was the first time they
opened that door and it's definitely
hard but I think a good hug will resolve
everything there was not a dry chair in
the room besides Jaden which was weird
it was definitely a very weird and
out-of-body experience it won't be the
losers Club
they had spend basically all the summer
together and they felt that this was
going away that this was you know the
end of this magical summer also because
they're all 13 I think at that time so
it wasn't only saying goodbye to each
other but I think very much like in the
book after that summer they were saying
goodbye to their childhoods
you